i know whoa
mark norman is joining us you're right
that was a stupid thing i just said yeah
oh you've been there yet did you go to
the uh the og studio yeah that's
hilarious this is weird yeah we like
this better though you get used to it
fast all right i prefer it yeah we were
just talking about the captain joining
twitter derek jeter's on twitter oh yeah
for the first time i used to bang a gal
who eventually revealed she used to [ __ ]
jeter
oh nice she said he was huge
oh he hit a big dick
oh good for jeter
so you didn't like that that you were
dari that you were you were with
somebody that had been with derek jeter
oh wow i'm the equipment guy you know
i'm a ball boy compared to this dude
he's a he's a man he's a half
what the [ __ ] was that
all of troy's equipment just comes
just it was the ghost of opie
but uh yeah yeah that was that was
boring but he gives you a care package
when he uh [ __ ] did she get the
basket oh she got the basket
what's in the carrot i've heard of it
it's roses and champagne and chocolates
and some cheeses it's all like high-end
[ __ ] that's
nice mark norman mark norman came in and
pushed all your [ __ ] off yeah i didn't
touch it
it actually just fell it just randomly
fell people complain about the gift
basket but i think it's a nice thing to
do here's a load have some flowers some
chocolates you get to bang a celebrity
and you get a bunch of free [ __ ] come on
is there a ball in there a sign ball uh
i don't know i don't know if he's
passing out those signed balls like that
that's uh yeah it's a lot of money i
don't know if a girl would care like
what am i a nine-year-old boy with
leukemia yeah yeah yeah help me yeah
that's going right to ebay if you're a
girl exactly yeah
yeah and he knows it she was a hot
number that girl was she how many times
you bang her a lot oh you did we had a
run she was newly divorced and she had a
kid we had to keep quiet and put in her
ass which is not easy no no
you put things in people's asses they
tend to squeal there's a lot of gymnos
yeah yeah you bet yeah yeah i've been
the giver and the receiver
that's a lot of information i've
squealed and i've made them squeal
[Laughter]
so was the was the derek jeter hookup
before the marriage or during oh
i think it was also after so it was
fresh
oh wow so it was like you were number
two after number two yeah i was batting
cleanup yeah yeah
i would walk into her bedroom in here
and i throw peanuts
i don't know i feel like i'd be excited
i mean it wasn't a relationship no it
was just a fling it was a hot thing she
was dating a struggling comedian with no
money and no act and no credentials what
ended it
uh
by the way you were slumming it for
after she [ __ ] arguably
the greatest yankee shortstop in history
and maybe the best shortstop in history
yeah she's [ __ ] like she's slumming
by [ __ ] you you're her dirty slumming
yes if anything you should feel good
about yourself like what are this lady's
options derek jeter and she chose me
good point right all right i'll take it
no i think what happened was jeter put
enough [ __ ] on her and he dumped her and
she's like what can i do i should kill
myself and then mark came along and she
said all right
i'll take a rebound one level up yeah
we're still friends though cool girl
now she's remarried the whole thing
oh it's a while ago oh it's just 10. oh
okay eight nine years ago yeah how long
did she [ __ ] derek for i think it was
the one and done oh bang
i'm glad he had a big hog that's good to
hear that's how he does it i wonder if
uh if she told her new husband
just said you know he's a yankee fan
hooked up with derek jeter and comedian
mark normand who
which one
hey speaking of comics how about rich
voss getting thrown off the reservation
wow are we allowed to talk about that
sure okay it's in the paper yeah voss uh
i mean you know he dealt with a heckler
i i it annoyed me this story cause he
thought with a heckler yeah like that
was it i know they left that part out
like you deal with a heckler and it's
news now it's silly that's a good point
well 30 people walked out according to
them
that's a [ __ ] uh do you think that's
true that 30 people walked out i don't
think he had 30 people at the show
that was his new year's eve
but believe me he would have been
bragging about that full house
well you know somebody made a good point
and i've heard it before but it's like
you go see a movie you google you watch
trailer whatever you go see a comedian
do the same but nobody does they go it's
a it's comedy it's this all-encompassing
umbrella in their defense i don't you
know googling rich voss may not you may
not have that much stuff come out
yeah you gotta be by his trunk
especially if it's a uh you're going to
see a headline commute like if you're at
the seller right you're not going to
google everyone on the lineup but if
you're going out for a night and you're
going hey i'm going to go see this
person you should know who you're going
this i've never done my life went to
something and not knowing what it was
i'm trying to buy a brownstone or
something not a brown stone
yeah buy something smart trying to buy
something brooklyn like get some space a
backyard live it up
so
covet hits i move out of my tiny
apartment and i i can't find anybody to
move in you know everybody's leaving the
city like crazy i get this old asian
lady she's she's super nice low
maintenance pays rent on time
you know happy with the price doesn't
bother anybody
two weeks in the building the board is
like she smells like ass her dog [ __ ] in
the lobby the cat pissed on the
stairwell yeah she's got a bird in there
she's cooking uh pork lo mein it's it's
wreaking up the whole of the whole
building we hate her you gotta get her
out gross so i finally found somebody
and then they wanted her one of their
out and so i had to be the middle man of
like hey lady you got to quit the
cooking hey you got to keep your dogs
out of the lobby hey we got to kill that
bird that's the thing that people don't
remember about like when they're like oh
yeah place and i'll i'll rent it out
like you just went from being a comedian
yes to being a landlord
you didn't sign up for this and you're
better at landlording
[Laughter]
so you uh you have to be the bad guy and
and tell her how do you how does she
respond when you tell like you got to
[ __ ] go it i i couldn't do it i'm too
scared of confrontation so i was like i
was trying to be the nice guy i was
trying to be like just cooler with the
cooking keep the door locked get a get a
fan in there or something a couple
candles and she was like okay okay then
months go by and they're like she's not
gone yet what the hell and they're
yelling at me
and i eventually have to tell her i i
just suck it up i grab my balls and i
call her and i i'm gonna tell her and
she she cuts me off and goes i love this
apartment so much i'd like to buy this
unit and i was like no
they hate you this is the exact opposite
thing i wanted to happen so uh she
bought it no
kidding but she uh she event i
eventually came clean and told her the
whole building hates you you got it and
she was crushed she was crushed she kind
of got weep weepy on the phone she
wasn't mad at you though not mad at me
she was sad sad and had no idea she's
like they're so nice to me they smile at
me in the hallways pieces of [ __ ] of
course of course yeah i guess but she's
smelling the whole place up yeah and the
piss and the [ __ ] piss and [ __ ] wouldn't
you love to hear mark be serious mark on
the phone like ah uh you gotta
go can't get me cooking too much you
know it's funny i almost got to a fist
fight on uh third street by the fat
black and i saw the bouncers there so i
knew i would you had to be all right so
you know there's all these kooks walking
around you know the village is crazy now
it's nuts you can't go two feet without
getting a hey you [ __ ] queef or
whatever that's colin
yeah
so um
this guy i'm walking with a friend my
friend's holding a camera and he goes
nice camera
f
you know oh wow and uh i go all right
all right jesus christ you know you just
want to walk by these guys but this guy
was a
a little aggressive for no reason and my
friend was like okay thank you and he
goes you wouldn't last a minute in jail
and i'm like what and he goes you heard
me f and i go [ __ ] you [ __ ] i just
couldn't take it anymore i was done had
enough yeah and i go [ __ ] you and this
guy wasn't huge he was like your size
you know and a little more handsome but
uh
he was like uh
well you called me a [ __ ] and i'm like
well you called me an f and he's like
well you called me a [ __ ] i'm like but
you called me an f so now i'm trying to
reason with this yeah
yeah yeah and by the way if that if that
what
sorry keep going okay so then now i'm
like walking backwards the fat black is
behind me i'm walking backwards to the
fat black and he's walking towards me
and i'm just going we're doing this
thing back and forth [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
i'll beat your ass i'll beat your ass
and i got the bouncers behind me and
eventually he's like do something do
something and we're we're face to face
and then of course steve the gigantic
black bouncer who's been there for 600
years puts his arm and goes all right
dude get the [ __ ] out of here and uh
so sean patton walked up another couple
comics and they were like your trash
talking is so
non-threatening it sounds like a bit the
whole thing it's like hey you [ __ ] what
are you okay get out of here kill
yourself who raised you hey and they all
did a number on me for 20 minutes on the
sidewalk but you know that guy didn't
really want to fight because he wouldn't
have said do something he would have
just hit you for saying that to him yeah
why don't you do something
as soon as somebody's probably just not
used to people saying something to him
right um you wouldn't last in jail yeah
but in jail it probably wouldn't go back
and forth like that if a guy's
what's his name danny trejo said that
like he would have a confrontation
if a guy would give him like that
posturing [ __ ] yeah he would walk up to
the guy and go [ __ ] your mother now what
like what if we're gonna fight let's
just fight get it over with yeah but
i've always heard let them push you
don't ever because you want to just go
all right and just punch the guy but
then then you can get in trouble i don't
want to get stabbed either though i
don't want to get shot or stabbed or
beaten up true but you'd be shocked who
has a knife in this town sean patton's
like i was ready and he just pulled out
a [ __ ] blade i was like who the hell
are you i guess you got to you know it's
like it's not crazy to assume that you
might get assaulted mace works but not
if somebody's really [ __ ] up on drugs
right oh i don't know about that yeah
you never know i guess if they're on
like bath salts or whatever they just
fight through everything yeah right they
just open their mouth
bring that mason yeah yeah that's why
jesus is good because you choke somebody
there's no getting it there's no blood
going in the brain doesn't matter how
high you are physically pass out yeah
but all the thoughts go like if i punch
this guy and then it cuts my knuckle and
he has aids and you start doing that
math and you're like he's so gross and
dirty and he's covered in [ __ ] so then
there's that that possibility with a
chokehold you gotta be in his [ __ ] i
don't know yeah that's the one thing if
you're gonna do jiu jitsu to a homeless
guy you kind of gotta get out of that
stuff that's right yeah that's gross
exactly yeah it has to be preservation
like he's gonna [ __ ] me up if i don't
choke him yeah i feel like
if fight or flight kicked in i'd be sure
i'd be flight we've done it with women
before like she's so gross but i got to
do this sure but you just had enough of
people saying [ __ ] for no reason i
couldn't take it and i'm not a tough guy
right but i just was like [ __ ] you i'm
done with it i know if you guys bully me
around i live in this neighborhood and
i'm sick of it yeah yeah i think that's
a lot of childhood starting to start to
boil up to the surface i was like uh
michael douglas in that movie falling
down falling down
guy then the yeah and the internet
everybody that's robbed your house in
new orleans growing up yeah
also this guy was five nine you know
that's helpful but you're not a giant
guy either though
yeah so
but i was like let's let's just do this
let's even if you beat my ass let's just
let's something's got to happen here
because i'm sick of just walking by you
guys this has been bubbling since
your your bike got stolen oh yeah good
enough
you've had enough if you by the way if
you were to
punch that guy and he would have hit his
head and died i'd still be on your side
all right
i mean he started it copy called us an f
yeah absolutely you can't [ __ ]
although you can't hit him for being
honest
[Laughter]
so you've been tooling around town in
the in the beamer is that the the
weather's good yeah yeah i got the
windows down i'm all over manhattan with
that thing i'm too scared to bring it on
out into another burrow because if it
dies and just shuts down i'm stuck
i'm all over the place what so you
haven't taken any real significantly
long trips in it too scared yeah the gas
gauge goes like this
it's like michael j fox with a pen it's
all over the place and i can't i can't
see how much gas i have i have to go all
like when's the last time what's wrong
with it what can you get that fixed i
probably could but it's these tiny
little needles that just wiggle and
they're hard to get get back in line i
guess
and i might actually have to get like a
little digital gauge and put it over
here but uh like an external thing yeah
yeah that's how much gas you have i need
to know so i'm scared to go out because
the other day i was in the upper west
side and i started it started up i put
it in reverse to get out of a parking
spot and it just died
started again here we go just died so i
had to push it to a gas station what was
it you're out of gas i was out of gas
some people do gas by mileage some
people like old school car people can do
gas by mileage like they know kind of
you know miles to the gallon and and
just look at the mileage and figure out
well it's it's my friend just bought a
tesla
and uh it's just fascinating to get in
this thing and it's so different like
he's literally doing his taxes he's
doing like the new york times crossword
and it's driving itself on the highway
oh self-driving self-driving the seats
are amazing he's got music going he's
got a podcast he's got netflix on this
giant screen you can watch stuff on the
screen you can watch anything that's
hilarious that's where it's going once
and once those get to be like they're
safe now but once they're safer and
everyone's got them everyone's got him
everybody will just be doing business on
the way yeah everybody you'll do
podcasts in a in a tesla yeah where are
you i'm on a 95 south you'll be doing
phones to radio stations plus they're
quiet so you can do a podcast totally
yeah yeah i was i was i mean i've been
thinking about a tesla for a while but
me too i went and got the car
filled up with gas over the weekend
those gas masks 97
higher than hunter biden that's crazy
that was the way i was when i when i
when i looked at it and it was 97 i'm
like this is getting to it's gonna be a
hundred dollars to fill up my car
i can't do it again you have a job
you're doing well like imagine something
like a landscaper guy or something yeah
yeah like that's like it's it's
completely cutting into your
your bottom line i don't even notice i
just say get in the car and go to work
bums stop crying wanting to stay home
sure i get that
six bucks it's just disgusting
but it's just fascinating to get in that
tesla and get back in my car and i'm
like okay uh first gear second clutch
brake clutch i love your lights mark i
love those two little those headlights
in the front there's two little on the
bumper there i bought those are fog
lights you can add them those are
awesome yeah they're fun they look great
you bought fog lights to add on but you
don't have a gas gauge yeah
the gas like an eyeball
but yeah it runs like a like a champion
how long was it pushing to a gas station
it i got lucky because the upper west
side is weirdly hilly so if you put if
you go towards the river it goes
there's a down slope well luckily the
gas in manhattan is super cheap yeah
yeah but the tank on this thing is like
the size of my [ __ ] it's tiny
just the opposite direction lots of room
for gas i love this coming from this
girl samantha is that yours no i stole
the car what do you think that's fine
why didn't you walk to the gas station
and get a and borrow a [ __ ] thing why
would you actually i don't know if they
give you a thing do they
you got to bring your own i think you
got to bring your own thing
you should have one in the back i guess
i should now but then also what are you
going to do just leave it on the street
ah yeah you can't steal this
yeah
and you know what why would you
yeah there's no gas in it
are you are you hoping that maybe
you know with the comedians in cars
you're like hey i got a car that we
could we could just use mine you know ah
sure sure he he when i bought he was
like send me photos i want to see it so
he was very
he was very he cared it was almost like
when your dad gives a [ __ ] for about
something for the first time yeah yeah
like you're actually bonding on
something yes yes like my dad doesn't
give a [ __ ] about anything right he
doesn't even know i do stand up he
doesn't know i live in new york but
i had him if i have a mole or something
or i need some physical
health thing he's all over it so you
even in the because now you're do it was
one thing when you were like you know up
and coming and stuff and your dad was
like i don't understand this and i don't
give a [ __ ] anyway but now that you're
doing like well like you're one of the
guys
he still doesn't care nah i mean i think
he's like oh that's good you're paying
the bills
i had a mole in my hair and he was he
was rubbing my head one day and he's
like what is this and it was a big mole
like a dime-sized mole and he's like
we got to get on it and i was like he
loves me
oh my god he's not paying attention and
we went to the hospital and he's like
he's got a mole we got to check it out
and they're like all right it's got to
be lance and i was like yeah that's it
yeah they were high-fiving then he found
out it wasn't cancer and he cried
yeah why'd you have a mole on your head
just had a mold grew up with a bowl and
it just uh you had to lance it it was
you know the sun hits it all day so
you're gonna start cutting yourself and
trying to get infections so you can get
daddy's attention
yeah i need to brace as a kid he was all
over that he wants to make sure that
you're healthy no just a reflection on
him he wants to make sure that mark is
healthy and looks good because dad
doesn't want to look sickly yeah because
he doesn't care what you're doing
yeah i never thought about that i'm
kidding
i was like you might have you really
gave him a crisis
it is interesting though that he doesn't
care what you do with your life
but he wants to make sure that you're
alive yeah you know it's hard for him to
show it he cares but it's hard for him
to show it yeah but with that stuff
there's an immediacy to health stuff
that's like all right we can't like none
of that stuff all that stuff about being
afraid to show it goes aside when
there's health issues those have to be
addressed do you think he's secretly
very proud of you i think so every now
and then you meet a friend of his and
he's like your dad talks about you and
i'm like what
yeah your friends are that weird of
course he's told people he's pretty good
he's out with jerry does he know that
your friends are saying oh yeah oh yeah
he cared that he was like whoa when's
the last time you saw jerry recently
right now well the pandemic's tough and
the pop-tart movie
oh this is the same thing you haven't
been on the show in months it's the same
story back then i know but he's not even
bouncing around like you should see him
at gotham a lot i don't see him there
anymore what are you doing in the
pop-tart movie i'm not i don't know if
i'm um i'm in the movie but uh
you know you never know when a role will
open up that's true still writing it
yeah maybe a comedian will die and i'll
slide in
when you buy a comedian i mean you mean
what's his name it was opening for him
ryan hamilton yeah when he got hit by a
bus i was like i'm back oh is he all
right yeah i forgot about that oh yeah
he's totally fine he's got 10 minutes on
it's killer
lights out i'm sorry to hear that for
yourself yeah
i bet it's really clean too well yeah
it's great it's clean and it's profound
and i texted jerry i was like you see
this uh this uh hamilton hit by a bus
chunk and he was like no
but i was like it's good
maybe
maybe we can bond for in our mutual
appreciation for ryan hamilton
you know dude he's very funny very
bright
killer yeah right yeah
i mean george shapiro died what do you
think i first thought i had was did you
hit him up oh yeah how did uh jerry
respond he said i know it's a shame
yeah
didn't it didn't didn't penetrate him
yeah i'm trying to go for that depth i'm
like a talk show host talking to paris
hilton i'm like elaborate please give me
more just letterman just sitting there
in the silence of it all he don't you
didn't know him either it's so it's
weird like when sure doesn't know
like sometimes i'll talk about a death
on the show somebody i didn't really
know but just you know and people give
condolences and i'm like why wasn't
friends really old i interviewed him
like you know i mean like right right i
know him extremely casually tomorrow
through saturday stand up live
huntsville alabama then on to timonium
and poughkeepsie minneapolis chicago
cleveland irvine all over the place go
to marknormandcomedy.com
uh for all those dates and uh it's
always fun man hey good times yeah good
to see you man i'm really good seeing
you